you inherit too much power
you have proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
the visuals on this film are incredible
the sound the production design the
costume design all of it was there a
moment or a day on set where you looked
around and your mind was blown and you
were like this is the next level many
days i would i would say 40 of the shoot
was that um you know i could say 80 of
the shoot was that because the sets were
built practically i think of the samwer
mural i think of the ornithopters the
spaceships those were all there
and uh
you know at the beginning of your i
don't know i feel like when you start an
acting career
the genre of projects you do are on
natural sets or natural environments so
this really felt like uh sort of a step
up in that regard just the level of
production design and level of actual
production was insanely huge and then
as and then i keep talking about to be
in the wadi room desert in jordan to go
to abu dhabi i got to finish in norway
you know those are the moments yeah you
know pinch yourself because it's like
this is uh it feels like work you know
between between quotations or something
for sure zendaya you know we your
character we see her in a lot of the
film but she does remain a bit
mysterious because her role is a lot
larger in the second part uh so what is
something that you learned about her
that you love and admire that you can
give to audiences now going into dune
part one who may not be as familiar with
the entire story right well i think
that's i think the cool part is uh is
that we don't know much about her yet at
least for people who haven't read the
books um or aren't familiar with them
you know uh we don't really know what to
expect from this person we've kind of
through his visions we've seen her be a
good guy we've seen her being bad guy
you know we we just uh we're
just as apprehensive about him as i'm
sure she is of of uh about her of us as
she is of him uh because they you know
uh we just these visions are confusing
and he's still trying to figure out what
they all mean and what is it that's
bringing him to these people and what is
this connection and
and uh she doesn't know that he knows
who she is um so i mean i'm fascinated
to you know kind of dig into the rest of
the story because there's so much uh
truly yet to come it really is only the
beginning um and i think
i
i enjoyed every moment that i spent on
that set you know like like he was
saying like just not only the cast and
the group of people that was there but
also these
gorgeous
natural rock formations that we got to
shoot in and i was just like this is
like
this is unreal like i'm living i'm in
arrakis like we're here we're doing this
like this is i'm on another planet it
truly felt that way uh in a lot of ways
so
yeah i'm excited and to be one with the
desert again
have you read the script for part two
like do you know i don't know i don't
even know i don't even know if they have
one ready to go
we're ready to go
we're ready to go
we wrote
a great man doesn't seek to lead
he's called to it
but if your answer is no
you'll still be the only thing i ever
needed you to be
my son
rebecca you know i'll start with you
you're no stranger to big blockbuster
filmmaking big action sequences this
film feels like it it's on another level
uh what is something that you got to do
on this film that that you've never
gotten to do making movies before
it's a hard one because it will easily
fall into what can sound like criticism
to other films that is not where i'm
going to take this
but i think
denny's love for this film was so
you know
on the surface all the time
that my focus wasn't on the grandiosity
of of the film the scale the landscape
that was there it was set
there wasn't enormous stunt sequences
there were a couple um but it was
the intricate scenes between the
characters it was deep diving into
a role and someone that he has nurtured
and that he knows and he knows where he
wants to take her and them and him
and just that dynamic i guess in this
scale was quite new to combine them
yeah
oscar you know
dune has inspired so many sci-fi
properties over the years including star
wars you uh sir have the rare
opportunity of saying that you have been
in both a dune and a star wars movie uh
how could you compare the two
experiences and like what did you uh
similar to rebecca what did you get to
do on june that that maybe you never got
to see or do making the star wars movies
rebecca was my chewbacca in this one
um
i keep on forgetting that he had a beard
in this movie he gets that i have a
beard in the movie i forgot
i forgot this apparently number one on
the cool shade yeah
beard was number one in the country
uh
i you know it was it it's just to say
what rebecca so articulately said it was
to work on something of this massive
scale
but it really was a constant exploration
and excavation of
the character
and the situation and the complexity of
what was going on and doing it in the
most economical way um you know
i would always go back to the book and
come up and say hey you know in the book
there's this thing i know that we're not
doing that is there a way to bring this
element into this scene or maybe we can
add did do that a lot yeah i felt really
bad because i hadn't that wasn't deep
diving as much i remember well you
already had so much to do you know there
was so much to do and there was some you
know but
but for the duke in particular i think
you know the way that he's presented in
the book it's a very specific thing and
then this is kind of changing that up a
bit so it was like trying to
bring in those elements and he was so
open to doing that and constantly doing
that so for me that was that was a very
different experience regardless of the
similarities of the scale without a
doubt and lastly what's your
relationship with sand after making a
movie like this like you swear off
beaches for a while or do you have like
a newfound respect for what was the most
exciting place you found sand
oh in your body can i tell
no can i tell you i did it wasn't for
june but we were filming in the same
location for mission after we'd filmed
june so i came back with the new crew of
mission the same hotel
the same landscape
we were doing scenes and i had a big
robe so when i came back to re-shoot my
pockets they hadn't emptied phil
from from june uh that's crazy i know
and my heart went to june
not to mention
dreams make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake
you've been in the the blockbusters
before you you played badass warriors
what was it about this film and this
role that just rocked your world and you
were like i gotta do it did
the director he's my favorite director
in the whole world so
i can't even believe he picked me it
wasn't even uh
even to this day i was like why
there's so many other better people out
there so it's a very humbling
and i'm just thankful to be a part of
this movie so
was there a moment on set that you
looked around and you and it kind of
just blew your mind you were like this
is next level filmmaking right here
uh that happened many times especially
when you're like jordan and you're like
and so we're out these deserts that are
just i've never seen anything like it's
like on a different planet it truly was
like you're on arrakis
but there were acting moments where i
was it's like where we meet
and we're all in lines as josh bowling
oscar timothy stephen we're all there
and uh
javier walks in and he's like dude this
guy is the boss bro
and he just delivers gold
he's so high so powerful
yeah that you just go well yeah i don't
know
think about it i think this guy's just
like
i'm just here as an extra and
thank you for hungarian me
i'll just be let's be the extra in your
movie
you know you you have experience now i
mean what is the more challenging
environment to film in water or sand
i mean water is always the worst
far is the hardest
everything's moving everything changes
light is like it waters water's the
hardest
do you have a does your relate what is
your relationship to sand after making a
film like this do you like
i don't know i don't like the sand yeah
i thought it was beautiful i think it
was really really pretty and i'm not
yeah the sand was
we didn't we weren't there for that long
so i mean like there for like two weeks
so to me it's just like wow what a
beautiful world that we have
when you take care of it there's so many
different
you don't experience that coming from
the midwest you know
yeah for sure you know i know you're
working on uh the next aquaman movie as
we speak what's a little something that
you know for the fans watching this that
you can tease about about your next
blockbuster afternoon
well
it was
this aquaman this time around i feel
like uh
pulling out all the stops buddy like
it's uh we all learned something on the
first one
it's exciting because you know i haven't
made too many sequels i just know that
it's
even all on the page it's absolutely
wonderful
there's so much going on i think the
stakes are a lot higher there's a lot of
comedy so i mean i eagle reading it
it's a lot of fun and uh
definitely the actions i think just in
the last three four years just
technology is
constantly it's just moving at such a
rapid pace that what we're doing with
underwater i mean that's what made the
first one so
just amazing
so it's just it's just going on to a
whole nother level so i'm excited for
everyone because it's just a lot more
hard a lot more at risk man sorry i
shouldn't even talk about it you got me
talking but i think the environmental
issues which really um i love about
being with the aquaman is like the two
worlds like what's important and what's
happening to our world so i'm excited to
i guess
open people's eyes and show it and show
some different sides and you know
smile gurney i am smiling uh josh you
have now worked with denis on multiple
films so how would you say his
filmmaking style or process maybe
differs from the coen brothers what do
you think makes him a unique visionary
for our time i mean
how every filmmaker is different from
from the other do you know what i mean i
mean the cohens are very specific in
their style and you know when you work
with some filmmakers they they they
resort to that a lot and i understand
they're like hey look at this shot this
is kind of like a clone brother shot and
then you realize you made a mistake um
but people like denise they really have
an originality and a uniqueness and an
ownership of their own vision and
i feel like denis i don't know man and
you know sicario was a wonderful movie
and i thought a rival was a great movie
but it feels like there's this upward
trajectory that was a practice
to do this and i'm not just saying that
and i haven't said it during every
interview but i i really feel that it's
like
he was really experimenting and learning
but also stayed within the scope of that
type of story this is so massive and i
think he was ready to do it i think it
was perfect timing for him right on
javier you have to do a lot of work in
and around sand in this film so like
what is your relationship with sand
after making a movie like this do you
swear off beaches for a while or do you
maybe have a newfound respect for sand
and the way that it informs an
environment especially in a film like
this
i don't know how to answer that
and i love the sand uh and and being in
the district of jordan is something it's
an amazing experience for sure and
because it's more than sun is yeah the
landscape is the bottom of the ocean
what what what once was the bottom of
the ocean
uh in some places and
the thing the thing with the the fremen
is the relationship with the the relate
their relationship with the landscape is
huge is unique and that's the thing that
you have to kind of
try to achieve the way they
relate physically to
that land to that
sand as you call it
and what do you think it is about that
makes this film such a unique sort of
inspiration for other sci-fi properties
you know it's inspired everything from
star wars to so many over the years what
do you think it is about this story uh
josh i'll ask you that that is the
original source you you see all these
you know yes there were a couple of
attempts and i think really you know
wonderful attempts but they were they
were great attempts for the times you
know it's been long enough and we've
we've advanced so much technologically
that you're able to
you know the lsd has gotten more
powerful
and uh and it allows you kind of to to
transcend in a much more sensorial level
you know and and it's the source
material i mean this is
this is what has inspired so many other
great things
it would be nice if the original source
material
we were able to see that manifested in
its
original greatness
all of civilization depends on it you
know i want to start out you know dune
uh has inspired so many sci-fi
properties over the years including
star wars
uh you know you have the rare
opportunity of saying that you were in
both a star wars movie and a dune movie
so i was just curious if you could just
compare the two experiences i mean to me
dune just feels so big in its scope and
ambition
yeah absolutely i mean they they are
both
you know huge scale entities and for me
my experience working on on star wars
was although you know it's that lovely
scene it was actually one day
so it's very different to me playing leo
kinds in in dune which is uh you know as
you say this is this is the beginning of
it all this is where all the sci-fi's
get all of their formulas you know the
the storyline plot lines everything that
we pluck out on on the average and if i
say average you know what i mean sci-fi
it comes from frank herbert's dune and
so
when you hold that bible in your hand
and you see it and then you look at that
as an actor and you go okay
i'm going to be playing somebody from
this
this is you know
it's it's an honor for me it's a it's a
huge honor and the more you know i
started to look into this world that is
frank herbert's world and and everything
that surrounds it i realized how
uh important it was for me to to
to treat it with the respect that it
deserves and um to also count my
blessings that i was allowed to be part
of it as well so
yeah you know i i want to talk to you
about the sand worm sequences your
character does is involved in in in a
sand worm sequence uh or two
what what did that look like from your
pov from an actress you'll be on set uh
when shooting those sequences
what it looks like was was me looking
into thin air and then denise shouting
then denis just shouting certain things
at me so it's coming and and it's get
it's that you that's when you get your
acting skills you know it's that thing
of like okay here we go we're imagining
there's this great worm which is
40 meters in diameter 400 meters long
what does that look like you know all of
a sudden you're starting to but but
denis is so wonderful we you know you
obviously talk about this and
at what point is it getting really when
does it become really colossal and and
so
yeah it's about investing investing that
lovely thing that we have called your
imagination and and being a child again
and and just letting it
wash you know
let it all come through through with
with just that sense of oh my gosh
because can you imagine can you imagine
that 400 i can't i can't i can't imagine
that you know but on that topic though
like what is your relationship with sand
after making a movie like this are you
like i can't go near sand
anymore like are you like no no beaches
for me for a while you know something i
always as a child
i haven't said this to anybody so far i
always as a child had had a problem with
how sand you used to feel when you went
to the beach and it gets stuck here and
it would come there i love sand now to
me sand is sacred yeah sandy and it's
from doing this it's from being in in
the places that we've filmed it's it's
been in abu dhabi it's it's being in in
wadi ram in jordan when you start to
realize what sand is it's it's it's time
i mean we always talk about you know the
passage of time when we use we use sand
visually to to to to portray that but
actually the truth of it is very much
that sand is
millions of years of the passage of time
and so when you think about
frank's what frank has written and how
long ago it was in in a short scale for
us you know just under 60 years and then
we think about where it's set in time
where this world is set and you just
sort of it starts to really um what's
the word i'm looking for it just it just
changed the way that i i envisaged most
sci-fi is let alone this world and
and how the endless possibilities that
can can occur because of that passage of
time but it also made me think about
just about the last couple of years
where we've been
and what we've achieved and what we've
learned and and the potential for so
many other positive things to occur in
our lifetime what can we do to make
things better and i think that was
something that frank
that was at the heart of what he was
writing so
yeah
every time i talk about it there's
something else that that i think well
and i'm sure you know that was that was
the plan from him you know to to wake us
up you know son
kill them all
god in heaven you know dune
served as an inspiration for star wars
and for many other sci-fi properties
over the years why do you think dune
deserves to stand alongside the all-time
classics of the genre and how does this
film help cement that status
um i think uh it'll be obvious when it
comes
when people are actually able to see
this film but it's just you know it was
all it was there on page but it was just
it took kind of the brilliance of a
danny venue to to bring it off the page
and put it on to film what she did in an
exceptional manner um i think obviously
it's going to stand along with all those
greats it's just
it's one of the most beautiful films
you've ever seen visually but it also
has the heart and the performances and
the story to go along with it i mean
when i watched this film i watched as a
fan
um
and at the end of this film i was just
processing it and just wanted more and
wanted to see more
and those are the types of films that
you really know are just going to stand
the test of time the the films that kind
of make you think and make you want more
so i think you know easily this is going
to stand out you know it's going to
stand alongside with those the films
like and they're all my favorites you
know star wars and even guardians of the
galaxy will stand up there with those
films and they're all different in tone
but still great films great stories uh
made by great filmmakers so i think uh
you know it's it's goes without saying
this is one of the greatest sci-fi films
ever made i can easily say that
yeah i totally agree it's uh it's uh
sci-fi is is a genre that that sometimes
have have sort of always
boarded to the ridiculous in terms of
decor and and the gadgets they try to
invent to make it look like some future
we don't know anything about and
but here in this film
uh the effort has been been put to to
create an absolutely new universe and no
unnecessary gadgets no unnecessary decor
it's it's there and it's alive this
universe and it's it's a universe you've
never seen and you really experience it
you you're you are
put in a very
beautiful poetic harsh and human
universe that denise has created on
based on on her herbert's books without
a doubt stellan you know you you are
unrecognizable in this film which has to
be uh i imagine a blast as an actor can
you talk about the physicality of
playing this character did you wear a
suit were you ever elevated in the air
like the character is at times i saw
something that said 80 hours of makeup
that you had to go through uh and then
also what did you just draw from in
terms of becoming the baron one of the
first things that i had the discussions
i had with with uh
the brilliant um uh makeup artist uh
louvre larson and eva fambar that
created this character is
and they know this i've worked with them
before it is you you got to make sure
that your face is visible somehow that
you can that you can still express
yourself with with your face and with
your eyes so if you look look at him
you can actually see it's me right and i
can express myself as much as i want
through it which is which is paramount
and and then then um
it was eight hours in in makeup every
day that was an ordeal and it was really
heavy to to wear so i actually had to go
to the gym and get a personal trainer
for the first time in my life
uh to be able to
dave could have done this without extra
training i couldn't because i don't
to wear a suit right to wear a suit like
that is it's 40 kilos and you want to be
able to move in it
uh so so that that was was hard work
but um there was another part of the
question that you said uh what was that
um yeah i just just to draw inspiration
like what to become the character like
what yeah yeah
i'm not a method actor i don't ever
become the character character i i mean
when i when i act i i act with myself
but i i the character becomes because i
deduct some parts of my personality and
add and and strengthen some parts of my
personality and then it becomes someone
else right
and i want to have as much latitude in
front of the camera as possible
now the important important thing is to
bring him to life
not
exactly how
and and when you work with denise it's
easy i mean you can try anything and you
you you become you beca you feel safe in
in this environment which means that you
get become brave and you you're allowed
to make mistakes and then you can try
anything and out of that comes all those
things that you couldn't plan at home in
front of the mirror
and it's those things that bring life
only together can we stand a chance
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
[Music]